foreign
gamespot's weekly hangout every Tuesday
at 2PM Pacific right here on
gamespot.com that's right my name is
Daniel dewire follow me on social media
and make me feel great it's been an
exciting week in video games Bayonetta 2
got a 10 out of 10 on videogames.com so
we're gonna have Jeff Grossman and Kevin
Von or the only people to ever well the
only people left in the building who
have given tens on Game Spot on the talk
about that Dan Riker the only person
who's played Bayonetta 2 in this
building right now for any period of
time is going to come on play it but for
the second week in a row we've got
guests
look at these guys we're guests oh my
God I dare say the best guests I need
better posture I I don't know the entire
Suite of guests you've had on the show
committed memory but this is the best
all of the names are on that wall over
there and we have three new names on the
wall right now uh Eric pope from
harmonics thank you very much coming on
hello watch camera man hi guys Alex you
Bailey fighting game community champion
hey guys what's up you've never actually
been a champion oh really yeah a few
things champion of the people thank you
and of course uh alt F1 uh co-presenter
uh Dave Lang so strong that podcast is
so strong it's going up right now oh get
ready as if there isn't enough Giant
Bomb references on this show already
like 20 seconds in look at that oh yeah
there he goes all the people don't you
love Eddie IL two sternovic people just
like wrote hardcore with passion all
over it I do think the there should be
some guidance on how much space people
should take because I try to be
conservative I just did a little thing
but then you look at that it's like it
just doesn't seem fair do you think it
should be based on importance no well I
think it should be dice rolls I think
it's your classic John Hancock problem
yeah the bigger egos take up the bigger
space okay oh really so molinew is the
one up on top does that surprise anybody
look at Vince sampela over on the left
right that's like a quarter of the whole
thing yeah I know sternovic guys as well
it all checks out it's good theory well
the problem next is that once more of
you jerks where the storm of it guys
we're gonna have to yeah you have to
erase yeah that's a problem yeah that's
why right there it's the second time you
said you don't like Europe um I love
Europe CBS Europe is like my fifth
favorite continent is that because
they're the fifth amended people who
bought dive cake and Killer Instinct uh
no that's well hold on carry the two I
love Europe everyone I'm just kidding
you send me to Gamescom oh really yeah
he only went to Gamescom because he
wanted to go to the spa Grand Prix no
well there was a contributing factor
yeah gamescom's a nightmare no one
should go to games you don't like
Gamescom it's like five conventions
smooshed into one with no air
conditioning no ice in the drinks we did
this thing where uh so I just go for
business meetings come the business guy
Andrew Bailey has to actually go work
the show and we were out drinking way
too late with some of his co-workers
like Annette and Nick and I just ruined
them like they tried to run with the big
dogs and could not hang were they
working the show they were working the
show right it's like in between my
meetings I just like strolled the show I
just see Nicki stops what he's doing he
starts flipping me off double Birds it
was very Furious you're a terrible
influence on my co-workers and that just
got kicked out of a bar last week
because of you really that's Chicago
that's true that is the Chicago yeah
Chicago tiny very nice little light and
she's just no don't put alcohol in her
she gets she's not nice to Abby Chicago
it's Chicago Chicago what about San
Francisco y'all are in for like one
night are you going to that Bruno Mars
concert that's on Hillary
Clinton's here this is the worst here on
Friday so you should be thankful that
we're here there's the Salesforce
conference all the hotels are booked and
if they're not booked they're 700 a
night so I so I got a shitty hotel by
the airport and I drove into the city
hundred dollars to park because of the
Giants game oh really everything's the
worst and because we're rolling this
deep baller status we just got a hotel
next door to you oh really yep right
there so we do it bam yeah I don't like
the phrasing of deep Ballers at all
speaking of deep baller status uh you
guys brought a Killer Instinct season
two yes it's at tomorrow October 15th
worldwide yeah yeah new characters yo
got two new characters at launch we've
got TJ combo and Maya uh did the launch
trailer today which I'm sure someone
from your fine site will put up for
everyone else it's probably up there
already tug in there we're getting
embargoes no no it's well that's
embargoed you're safe is it not is this
live yes oh shut it down no
um they announced Cinder ripped her
coming back a whole bunch of good stuff
oh look at it oh there we go there got
it up nice
holy cow what happened to TJ's arms he's
all caught up in he's cybernetic now he
ripped he ripped out all the ultra Tech
that was in him right and now he's 100
organic he was sick and people are
giving him crap about it he's got he's
got he's beefing with ultra Tech
Maya Maya Maya yes the 3D modeling
software
mine is pretty god-like are we gonna get
to play some of these yes I think what
we'll do is uh me and jabelia let's do
some matches and show some TJ Maya stuff
just do a couple like hey here's what
she can do here's what it is here's the
stages and then I will body him on live
stream for the world to see all right
let's get to it then all right sir me
and me and Pope can uh can Shout cast
yep we are going to get to your game
later on yeah just in case people think
yeah no I'm just hanging out just turn
up I've got my own game guys he just
sits here and drinks Starbucks for like
an hour
so you want to just show my real quick
and then talk about yeah while you're
doing it
so Maya nobody's really gotten their
hands on her until tomorrow's launch
people have had Early Access with TJ
combo um and she's a pretty good
character she based uh basically on all
her daggers that she uses they're called
Temperance and Vengeance and basically
doing a fireball motion will throw one
or the other at you and if they block it
Powers up her dagger okay now with her
daggers when you throw it it's not like
a typical Fireball you have to actually
go back and get those daggers so the
premise is like when she has her daggers
she's super scary and super powerful but
to charge up the daggers she kind of has
to get rid of them so go ahead and throw
one
it's right there that kind of like so
the HUD there in the lower right corner
you see the every time so if I block go
and throw them again
the daggers get more Pips so now they're
fully charged and can do some Shannon is
there any way the other player can reset
them uh no I can't pick them in combos
uh you can pick up them by pressing
three punches or if you do a roll or any
of your mid combos look she'll gather
them so let me get rid of those bad boys
I just wanted to point out I noticed the
gfb industries in the back
how did that get in there a little shout
out it's a mid combo I can do this stop
blocking Dave okay
Oh wrong way oh my God
let's see if I can get back there so in
the mid combo should be able to get her
daggers back well this is TJ stage
Christ and uh yeah not right now it's
not
and she has a nice cool little aircraft
she has to have just down and spear
punch as you're jumping in there yeah
it's actually a great mix up because the
only way if you're fighting my you have
to duck to get out of the way and you
can cancel out of the jump and do an
overhead so it's like it's kind of like
a 50 50 mix-up and when her uh daggers
are powered up you can end your combos
with level four Ender if they're fully
powered does a whole ton of extra damage
and the cool thing about her is her
Mobility not many characters have this
where she can roll forward and jump in
the middle of the Roll to jump faster
and higher so that way you know I want
to get my dagger back and just go and
get it back pretty much it's incredible
how much of the the sort of the nuancing
these fighting games is down to that
sort of stuff like you're no stranger to
it at all with your work at CEO like
it's funny how
like when you're making these games now
because the fighting a community is so
big like are you literally making it for
that community and not like just a
everyday you know dude wants to pick up
well not not at all for KI like Ki very
deliberately some of the characters are
really easy to pick up and play like
like characters like Maya and uh like
Diego are very traditional kind of like
execution Motions like quarter circles
or emotions or whatever but there's
characters like TJ or like saberwolf who
are really simple like just back and
forth and up and down on the stick and
the thinking being that you know we want
as many people to try the game as
possible we want to make it as
accessible as possible so there have to
be some characters that are kind of like
easy that anyone can kind of get in
there and use and so but we still do
want like you know the super super high
skill ceiling crazy execution to combo
stuff for you know people have been
doing this their whole lives like Alex
here so was there a character with seven
characters or eight or nine characters
in uh season one when you guys launched
the end of last year there's eight eight
characters yep plus Shadows limited yeah
uh we haven't talked about in season two
yet uh or if we will at all but uh so we
did announce in the trail there's eight
characters we have publicly said that
there's four returning characters from
the original series and then four new
ones which we give you a hint at in the
trailer itself so we'll be talking about
we've announced that we're having a new
character or a character two season two
once every month okay another was Maya
Cinder
on TJ as well yeah yeah okay cool those
are the four return then four other
characters which people haven't seen
quite yet and then what about the stages
is there one for each one of those yes
or you got some more in there yeah
there'll be one for each new character
as well now this I'll show you is the
first stage to have a stage Ultra in the
game yeah I'll chill out sweet let me
give you mess it up yeah I don't need it
can I sit up
cool thing about her is just the tricks
that she can do with her daggers
it's been super fun for us to work on
because if if anyone has been familiar
with iron Galaxy and some of the stuff
we've done like we started off doing a
lot of ports for Capcom like third
strike Marvel Capcom Origins dark
stalkers and do those partially just
because we really like those games a lot
and really love fighting games I have a
lot of people there who just kind of
live and breed that stuff then you know
dive kick last year and then you know
last week on next gen and get a chance
to do something like this that is like
you know a wholly original like
legitimate work in the fighting game
Space it's been super rewarding for
everyone in the studio it's been crazy
fun it's not like a bunch of
responsibility when you got given like
an IP like this and kind of told yo
here's something that a bunch of people
really like don't mess it up yeah it was
It was kind of double whammy for us
because uh you know the double helix did
season one of this right and they did it
amazing oh there it is and now it's time
for everyone
Field of Dreams that was my only that
was my only creative guidance in this
whole project as I said make that like
Field of Dreams
um yeah and those guys did an amazing
job and so like one kind of like not one
just to meet what they did but try to
surpass it in a lot of ways too it was
super super challenging but uh you know
without the job they did we wouldn't
even be here today right now so shout
outs to double helix and those guys
so TJ uh TJ's got a couple like his his
most unique mechanic he's got uh
recaptures for the first time so
um with season one you could do a lot of
like launching characters in the air but
that would kind of end your combo you
couldn't do a lot with it and so TJ can
actually kind of keep combos going with
this recapture
Alex they're demonstrating combo
breakers thank you Alex
um but his bread and butter is really
the power line so he's got this move
it's kind of like back up a bit yeah
he's got like this full screen attack uh
but he's got a bunch of things he can do
off of that so you can come in and you
can grab off of that and capture
and then uh so off of that he can also
back up please
so you can also fake it cancel out of
that um you can roll uh and do things
and then finally my favorite
is the knee out of that and so he's got
a lot of options to get in really close
if he's confident you're not gonna you
know do anything like say Maya throws a
dagger that's all bad ideas
um when you do the
um Shadow version of this it's actually
got armor so actually if you throw in go
get those
and throwing at me when I'm doing the
together
so up too far but yeah so the [__] that
version's got uh armor so you can kind
of get through attacks and get all the
way in
and there's a daggers only charge up
when the block happens that you yeah it
has to block for that to happen
but it doesn't change the usability you
can always throw them any way you want
in the air on the ground
uh now her Instinct mode is really cool
when you activate Instinct mode her
daggers always return to her so you can
do cool stuff like that and then the
middle of the combo
but yeah so I'm throwing a if I throw
this at him I have enough time to get
all the way over to him
to finish a combo so that's really cool
very tricky so if he's blocking that I'm
coming in as he's blocking and it gives
me the chance for a couple Mix-Ups
uh does anyone has any questions in the
chat by all means I sent him in first
one coming in shondan asks what gfb
industries be in every iron Galaxy game
from now on uh if I were all part of gfb
Industries gfb Industries lives inside
all of us at all times
like the bottom line with gfb Industries
I'm not going to say that out loud
explain to a dummy like me what is the
deal what is the deal with the season
different way of saying it's part two
Yeah so basically there was uh you know
so I guess for those who don't know
anything about Killer Instinct talk
about this for a minute so it's a free
to play game right so you can download
the whole thing for free
um it kind of works on like a league of
legend style basis where there's one
character that's typically free and you
can try them out and then if you wanna I
think it'll swap that out you can buy
like five bucks per character or you can
buy the whole a lot of bundled content
for cheaper and so yeah so it's kind of
just a way to demarc those bundles
essentially right so you can get all the
season one stuff in a bundle all the
season two stuff in a bundle I'm sure
when we're done with season two they'll
bundle all that stuff together at a
discount as well uh but yeah it's kind
of just an easy way to kind of demarc
some of those bundles cool is there any
plan to keep going with this bad boy
season three uh you know a lot of it uh
we would love to obviously the user base
is growing well it can only be going on
the Xbox one yeah I mean it's it's
there's this element to this of uh where
it seems like
uh
uh free to play it's just gonna get
better and better and better on consoles
as people keep buying them and buying
them buying them let's go to my stage
real quick show that off
um
and so yeah so it seems like it's got
there's a really good chance that he's
going to grow and grow and grow as long
as we give him compelling stuff to keep
doing you know
um so I really hope we get to do season
three but we probably the reality is we
probably won't know about that for quite
a while when kind of get the numbers in
and see how this is doing yeah so I mean
that's one of the things that sucks
about game development right is like hey
I want to do this thing and this thing
and this thing and this thing oh but no
one bought the last thing so you don't
get to do any of that and now you go cry
in your room for an hour I'm gonna buy
it so I can stay with iron Galaxy
forever and ever yeah this is actually
one thing Bailey's employment is
contingent on there being a season three
so if you think he's got what he he's a
smooth looking character over here on
the couch I don't know why you would
think that but say hypothetically you
did uh and you'll screw this
is that confirmation that there won't be
a dive kick too then
why make that game
it's only an action script anyway so you
can just that's cute with the flash
jokes
hit a button
dude so is that actually your background
you were a fighting game champ uh so
I've been a you know I've been playing
Street Fighter Mortal Kombat Growing Up
played a lot of Killer Instinct 2 in the
arcades uh so I've always been a
competitor playing it and I started my
own tournament Series in Orlando called
CEO you guys do it differently to a lot
of uh a lot of other organizations you
guys use the Rings and stuff right uh I
use the ring yeah it's been done before
but I like to make it the theme because
I'm a huge wrestling fan in our
generation of fighting game players are
from the NWO Attitude Era so I brought
everyone's like oh this is crazy
um so I themed my stuff a lot around
that that's how I first met Dave
actually yeah yeah when I met Adam Keats
uh Adam Hart who's the lead comic
designer for this game who created dive
kick
um you know I saw the game like bring it
to my event let's check it out and then
I told him put me in the games like why
like I get a big head when I went around
he's like you're in the game so and
that's how I met Dave and then you know
yeah
for the first time in my experience Dr
Bailey's actually being a little modest
um his tournament is the second biggest
fighting game tournament in the world
only second to Evo wow and it's growing
like crazy man right so I mean with that
part it started out with you know 300
people five years ago it had 2 800 this
year you know no big deal but where can
people find out more uh go to ultra dash
combo.com for the official forums and if
you there there is a website going up
that's up right now yeah we are
remodeling Dash combo excuse me yeah
Ultra hyphencombo.com uh I'm the lead
moderator on it so anytime you want to
reach out to me on Twitter CEO de Bailey
we're always listening that's the beauty
of working with these guys is relaying
the community and their thoughts about
the game I sent it straight over to
Microsoft so and coming from the fact
that I've been playing fighting game for
20 years I know what's a pin pin out and
go hey this could be a problem or hey
they really love this let's add to that
so is that where you get big arms like
that you just gotta play lots of playing
games I do CrossFit so God damn it just
lie to me
who's winning this
looks like I bought it yeah I was
talking the whole time
I get free dinner tonight
well thank you thank you that was a hoot
thanks for uh for coming on do you want
to stick around
I want to see popes baby all right this
is great it's it's like showing I want
to play it since you don't know how you
said wow
I said that actually if we have time I'd
like to pass it around see how our folks
do so yeah they do big fan of everything
sleeps is that when it comes out two
days from today the 16th on Steam so the
game is called the city sleeps uh it is
a twin stick shooter it's a musical twin
stick shooter it's on steam pc and Mac
so all of these things are brand new for
harmonics yeah right we made rock bands
we made amplitude uh Dance Central
um but so basically the team that made
this sort of in the same way that you
were like a hardcore fighting game guy
uh the team that made this are really
big into those 90s style really hard
hardcore
yeah yeah
like I mentioned uh so first first time
for harmonics in a lot of ways
um so we're uh you know it's a 15 game
on Steam 15 off this week right 15 off
if you get it now if you pre-order it
now 10 off when we go to uh the launch
week and then full price and then
there's another bonus if you buy the
Russian version you will have the added
bonus of really perplexing yeah Dave
apparently bought the Russian version
which I didn't know was possible yeah I
just went there and bought it but yeah
uh what you'll hope hopefully see isn't
the Russian version just like a download
yeah if you don't pay for it those guys
just show up in your steam forums like
uh Russian keys to sell
I've blocked a bunch of them but uh
hopefully what you'll see if we're not
yammering too much is uh everything in
this game is driven by music and it's an
amazing score is that you like like
telling us to shut the [__] up no no
it's sort of the curse of a lot of
harmonics games is that they sound
really cool so it's like you really need
to see it together
so so
I'm just gonna jump into it here you
play as Poe that's Poe right there and
the white shirt and the uh yellow shorts
this is her apartment as you navigate
the menu here you sort of Explore her
apartment so she is a dream Exorcist
that sounds like that sounds like she
made that up yeah she's from a clan
called the silk they've been dream
exorcists for like hundreds of years
this is in a an alternate future uh city
called sanlow so in her day-to-day life
you would just go to her if you have
nightmares you can go into your
nightmares and clean out the demons uh
but basically the story of the game is
uh the entire city uh is locked into
nightmares and they can't wake up and
obviously she's special equipped to deal
with that and she works with these
ghosts these are her familiars so these
are these will help you in combat I
mentioned it's a twin stick shooter I'm
going to jump into combat real soon so
you don't have to just see the shell but
you have these uh ghosts that you can
Equip to use in combat so like the anger
ghost is an offensive ghost so when you
get into the game there are these Idols
that you can deploy ghosts into that's
where you see the little triangle and
square there there are two types of
Idols so we've sort of layered this
almost Tower Defense mechanic onto the
classic like bullet hell genre what's
the purple one the purple one is loyalty
it freezes enemies which is pretty
helpful and also does a chain strike so
yeah you have two different outputs for
each of these ghosts and you unlock
we've unlocked everything right now just
for the sake of demoing you'll lock them
as you play and they each drastically
change your style of playing so for the
sake of this demo I'm going to go with
anger who helps me offensively Mercy who
can heal me in combat uh and master
who's like an overall badass it does it
does damage it's a little more advanced
though it's based on your location on
the screen so is that mostly like a
personal style thing or do you need to
do like you don't have to do specific
ones to like no no it's definitely
personal style what works best for you
um because I've been demoing the game
these are the three that work best for
me right
um well we'll be to judge of that yeah I
am terrible I am garbage at this game
the purple one reminds me of the badass
version of the raisin guy oh yeah yeah
this game was was fired by the
California Raisins
so everything's on right now that's why
they're all xed out like that but
basically you would play through our
difficulties our reverie which is
basically easy if you're not a hardcore
shmups player like myself you can play
through the game on reverie and you can
really soak in the atmosphere and the
music and you don't have to be really
good Lucid is your normal difficulty and
then from there we unlock these we have
these cursed Lucid cursed so a little
twist on everything like for instance in
this cursed level there's extra
projectiles there's Nightmare and the
nightmare cursed single hit kill night
terrors yeah so uh there's a lot to dig
into actually I think there could be a
good Crossover with the killer instant
Community like those are people that
like a good challenge out of their games
are pretty hardcore do you think the
killer Institute Community would like
this game he hasn't seen it yet I
haven't seen it yet
a lot of ddrs I love any rhythm game all
right so every level in the game is a
different person's nightmare so I'm
going to jump into level one right now
and uh it's hard to talk and play and
not be garbage well that's okay because
I'm just gonna completely cover you in
questions like
um so if people can hear right now when
I shoot
that's adding a stream of music onto the
soundtrack I don't know if we can get a
little more audio in the house yeah
let's go let's crank it up a bit
as these enemies spawn in they're their
own Lair of the soundtrack
so Mary's Mary's on it okay so
everything in the game that I mentioned
uh builds the soundtrack
so right now these are just enemies
spawned in as the first exposure to the
game right so now that these guys have
appeared in their shooting their
projectiles are part of the soundtrack
and this thing that you see over here is
our first Idol so I can slow down time
with the right trigger
cycle through them uh so I chose the
anger ghost that's sort of like a
machine gun effect helps me fight these
dudes with the holes in their chest so
it was the idea with the music stuff
that you can kind of anticipate shots
yeah so with shoot em ups and generally
a lot of the gameplay
on memories memorizing the spawn points
and the levels and this game is not
really different in that respect but
what's different is
it's a lot more intuitive when it's tied
to a score
a soundtrack score not like I don't know
yeah
so one thing you'll notice I put in the
mercy ghost which is giving me all this
awesome healing but if you look at my
score it's actually a negative 20 yeah
modifier because uh I'm a big baby and
I'm being penalized for being a big baby
um also when I get close my attack turns
into a melee and that's super important
um when I do enough melee I'm collecting
this red energy I can do my special
attack which is very important for some
of the mid-level bosses and stuff and
also stuff is kind of like it's spawning
in all over the place as opposed to just
streaming from the right of the screen
constantly
let me switch to master so you can see
what he's all about don't get yourself
killed in there the master is pretty
powerful
and you see my swords going red now so I
have my special charge it up which is
pretty good I'm gonna need it at some
point soon so what makes the modifier go
up and down because I see it like not
just that 20 it's going 1918 and back in
the positive yep that's uh my streak as
I play
so here we go
there's a little bar next to it that's
like a cool down so if I can get another
kill before that bar cools down you can
do it
add to my
here this is a pretty weird dream I've
never had a dream like this yeah this
dream's so that's the thing like this
dream is really focused on bugs and
pretty disgusting I had a dream last
night where I was uh I was my mother
um in my house and there was all these
people trying to kill me but I was I
think it's because I was playing too
much Shadow of Mordor that I was I was
crawling into like the stealth around my
house is that is that dream in this
video game uh that will be coming as DLC
if you just give me a pretty good idea I
had a dream that Dave actually threw me
out the 24th floor of the West really
yeah it's a glass window man it was
scary
he tried to do it all right so this is
like a mid-level boss here if I were on
a higher difficulty uh what you'd see is
way more intense bullet patterns
uh in a lot more of the projectiles
the higher difficulties also you'll have
more enemies
spawning in at a time to
and like you said there's one mode where
just one hit kills so any of those
touches yeah yeah so that's my special
attack giant does damage you happen like
is it just it hits you and then you're
damaged or is it how long something is
touching you you get more damage every
hit is damaged and I should also point
out that I only take damage in that
green circle in Poe's chest that's her
hitbox right so I don't need to worry
about my legs
um
how many of these what are they totems
or other ones called them Idols Idols
how many of those can be on screen any
one time uh two at a time Max a lot of
times you'll only have one
um a lot of the tough tougher boss
battles if I do well enough to get to
the boss of this level they'll go away
completely and you're sort of on your
own
um
getting this this question always
happens when a game has a pretty good
soundtrack uh can you is this soundtrack
available like separate from the game at
all yeah with the game you guys have a
deluxe edition right yeah we have a
deluxe edition on Steam that gets you
the soundtrack
um the soundtrack when we go live should
also be available on Steam Standalone
we're also putting up a bandcamp page on
harmonicmusic.com it's a heads up the
Russian version does not include the
soundtrack oh man
sorry Russia it's just a Russian
national anthem over and over and over
again hey as far as national anthems go
that's a good one it's really
intimidating so I drive I drive a Prius
hey Dave no this is best hold on and so
there's always this dude in the parking
lot whenever I pull in he's like walking
in the middle of the street and actually
this is a long story sorry
and so he never hears the Prius creeping
up behind him and so that I started
going straight out of Red October and I
would just play the Russian national
anthem and he can hear singing and he
gets out of the way it's amazing I have
a playlist on my iPad for immediate or
my iPad for media to access oh wow
that's badass yeah this is uh level
one's boss I guarantee I'm not gonna
make it how many levels are there uh so
every level is a different person's
dream so there are three different
dreams uh that are coming in the game
again it's 15 game so it's not like a
full 60 retail title uh the focus of the
gameplay is really on the replayability
so like right now I'm on normal
difficulty
uh what I would want to ideally do
is get better at the game so I can play
a nightmare and not be a chump is that
is a three levels three songs is it
three songs yep were they done
internally yes they're all done by one
guy in-house his name is mq that's his
artist name he's a he's put out a lot of
music in the uh sort of
experimental electronic Hip Hop
field I mean it's amazing have you guys
had original music in your games before
uh here and there so Fantasia which
comes out next week actually has a ton a
lot of focus on remixing so we got to
have a lot of harmonics
audio dudes contribute their own remixes
to songs like Peter Gabriel's in your
eyes stuff like that right which is
pretty incredible maybe even rock band
had some house band stuff in it oh yeah
yeah
so as you can see I'm not jumping I'm
just
alert right now because I want you to
see
his boss that's fine you got it how big
is the team doing this Pope the team on
this game is about six people Eric Eric
made it himself in action script nice so
this is where I die the way to do it oh
Jesus luckily I saved up my sword so I
can do some damage whoa all right oh God
uh I can't pretty good at this man I'm
not I'm really not freaking the [__] I
can't this is
so so as I said everything's driven by
music even the bullet patterns are
driven by the midi of the song So this
they were able to do like rock band
style lanes for this one boss is a
little bit of a you have a secret
warning at the beginning yeah Jesus
Christ
is there a bomb that blows up the screen
do you have anything like that so that's
what that big sword is that's our take
on a bomb nice okay you can swing it
around 360 Degrees
um
and so in addition to those curses that
I show you also unlock a lot of relics
I'll show you those so those are all
their gameplay modifiers so like you can
um
increase your speed right you can boost
some of your ghost abilities
pretty cool so if anybody
if you want to take a crack can be the
hardest level here we go oh yes yes the
hardest level on like like hardest
difficulty no not the one hit though
that's that's Overkill all right like
medium level but the hardest level oh oh
Jesus oh you know the heart you know
what I'm the hardest level yeah all
right
all right give him the niche how did you
do the dash Bailey talks a lot Dash is
right okay yes okay Dash is Right bumper
trigger is what slows down time you can
hold it as long as you want it doesn't
stop time but it slows it down you can
cycle through your ghost to the left
bumper okay
those will automatically deploy to the
highlighted idle you can switch your
Idols with the right tracker I'm sorry
the right quarter roll X to Deer special
okay you can do nightmare cursed
no no that that was on the other level
oh okay all right on this level is once
a ghost is placed in idle it can't be
changed
so you can't like switch on the Fly oh
she's the health not a terrible curse
um all right and it's a level you have
not seen so this will be interesting
this level so you'll see like each level
has its own a performance a visual look
and feel there's a lot of there's a lot
riding on this you didn't know about
that's fine
got it
could we be quiet so we can listen to
the music and play better
I mean the soundtrack is really
incredible like
you're such a good can she Dash forever
yeah there's just a bit of a cooldown a
couple beats of cooldown afterwards
uh
d-boy Mr Maestro says last night he
dreamed he was in an NWA music video
I said I felt uncomfortable at first but
Easy E was cool all right all right
surprisingly easy
you think yeah he seems like he'd be the
biggest wild card of a bunch he
definitely had the most
EMF about him
two nights ago Seth Frost was dreaming
about fighting the alien out on your
health emptying his code and then so
that's the curse you can't change them
now oh God dang it
oh no okay I'm okay
how much longer is he gonna survive Bob
slow down time have you slow down good
job am I dead already another try okay
oh so there's no continue once you die
you start over yeah so if had you made
it to the second stage you would start
on stage two you don't have to start
from them so how do I follow yourself
free at this no I was trying to do my
health do the house left bumper
also it looks like you lost your master
ghost that was a bug I noticed earlier
that I forgot to tell you thanks Chief
is the game shipping with bugs uh
probably the Russian version what game
doesn't ship with bugs absolutely
get these things off of me holy crap
this is a challenge so you should yeah
just keep your teacher keep your guns
blazing no I think this is part of it
though like these people who like I love
these games and part of it I love is
like the Mastery aspect exactly so like
I I was never into that type of game
until it's really suck
figure out how to beat a section of the
level you don't break your console by
then this is really incredible yeah
there's just not a lot of genres left
where
still fun to lose over and over and over
again and I feel like this is one of
them yeah like Mordor is pretty
difficult
pretty fast in that game maybe I haven't
played enough it's pretty open world
though there's a lot to do yeah have you
played Phoenix rage
that's that's pretty though
I like that you're lumping these all
these games so can I shoot faster it's a
set it's always a set Pace yeah the
shooting is set to the sound okay good
it's pretty good this is good just keep
just keep running just keep running away
okay watch out just like Dave in
fighting games just run away
oh my God yeah this is uh yeah you're
not Invincible as a crash either so yeah
you might want to change that yeah if
you dash you're like you're basically
definitely going to get hit I think
people Universal universally expect to
be Invincible during dance so we had
that we had that and we found that was
not hard enough Dave would you like to
give it a shot yeah Dave you should give
it a shot so God like let's go let's see
who gets farther
that wasn't fair we'll restart
video games aren't Fair what are the
controls oh God yeah he doesn't have to
move right to that right bumpers Dash I
got this and then trigger to slow down
time oh yeah uh left uh left trigger
when you have your special attack left
bumper to cycle through your ghosts I
don't think you're gonna get that far
every time I see Dave playing a video
game I'm impressed I'm like he doesn't
just make money off this stuff yeah he's
not just a [__] talker well to be fair
I mean you're a really good [__] talker
so like my one of my favorite games from
two years ago was sign Mora yep is it
sign more or whatever
cyan Mora it's like a Kim my favorite
game
who's got time to learn how to pronounce
these game names man you should put your
ghosts in those Idols
right trigger
whoa nope oh there's a Slowdown I'm just
kidding
yeah that's not the health one if you
played this level what what would you
pick
the health
um so the first thing I would do is not
play with curse mode on oh I would be
switching it up a lot
um I switched to health a lot because I
suck and I ended up needing it so this
is actually a good spread that Dave's
done he's done the attack and the health
one nice work Dave even though he did it
by accident oh God like who had a higher
score should have kept trying now these
are like when it comes to like events
like my own or just in general it's
great to have these kind of games
especially you have like I've seen uh
events have reso gun challenges Bailey
are here for iron Galaxy not CEO yeah so
on dive kick there's a score and no tell
me about Resogun all right Dave watch
out for the lotuses
get out of there
we're good
um so if you want to look up so mq I was
mentioning is the artist he has his own
bandcamp page that's M
dashq.bandcamp.com he's got a bunch of
albums so if you like what you hear go
support him he's a badass I am vaguely
infuriated that I can't my shooting's
governed by the music thank you I I feel
that I want the music to be faster
that's only something in this like yeah
it depends on the level really yeah so
you sort of is there one where it's just
constant barrage yeah
that's level three it makes it more
challenging this way I do I do
appreciate that is Darude Sandstorm in
this game not yet
The Final Countdown
we haven't uh delved the rock band style
licensed DLC yet are you guys going to
do any Post Release
uh I would hope get away I would love to
do uh release some more levels release
going at all
I gotta get my melee up we'll see yeah
you do but be careful I'm just waiting
for this YouTube video that does the one
hit kill mode It Never Dies yep
oh fudge
if this health give me all this health
melee may like oh my God it's the worst
have you done better no the Lotus is
love and come up yet have they
uh lotuses are after this part oh my God
so if I were to Dave I would save up my
melee to get my sword oh there you go
to kill the lotuses but all right you've
already done better than last time all
right you just gotta survive Dave don't
move around too much don't tell me what
to do
just don't forget I'm My Own Boss sir
what's up
he's like oh look at the pretty slow
down I gotta stay by the health I think
if I go to hell no matter what if as
long as I pick up Health at all times
you're actually
I got this figured out let's go to get
help I do like the design of how the
health doesn't just come from the center
it actually spreads itself out so you
can't
just camp camp in one area oh no you got
it my whole plan is asunder I believe
you survived
don't no [__] it up no it's not right
I'm so god-like
so are those thumb tacks or needles uh
needles my eyes are watering yeah my
eyes are like don't blink the eyes hurt
Dave heal up how do you do that oh Jesus
oh God
oh
I've never seen again great
airport that's a city sleeps that means
you've so the California Raisins on our
galaxy are now going to have lawsuits
against you yeah oh my God raisins are
surprisingly litigious Dave but it was
over there oh my God
so October 16th this week Thursday on
Steam it comes out there's a deluxe
edition if you want the soundtrack go to
citysleeps.com it'll automatically
direct you to the steam page or
charity go to humble.com
humblebundle.com you can buy there as
well and 10 of the proceeds go to
charity that's the third game you should
buy this week what the Humble Bundle no
a city sleeps third what's the second
first is dive kick okay for Xbox One or
PS4 available now Killer Instinct season
two should buy them both friends are
legitimately
and then you should buy a city sleeps
please buy if you want to see harmonics
put out more games like
I still have to buy it
Eric Pope box your baby Dave Lang thank
you very much for coming on thank you
for having us showing us your wares uh
yeah I know right it's just so emotional
the music is so good guy in two seconds
Jesus Christ is that how you get pink
eye if you want the hype levels are real
on your show
sorry
oh God Bless America all right you have
the con
ibola
Borderlands 2 Pre-Sequel oh in just a
few minutes once we check in with that
really terrible Irish accent in that new
Assassin's Creed game roll it
Peggy 18.
Shay was an assassin
admit it I nearly had you he was a
friend a brother what did I miss only
the first hour of training a Pity the
boy has so much potential but so little
discipline I have tracked the Templar as
far as this Coast but I fear the rest is
up to you my friend
you made me Slaughter innocence I will
not let this happen again
our brother
he's coming to hunt us all
highly of you say
the best Among Us
respect will not disappoint I don't plan
to sir
you will fail
every last man who defends him if I must
what is it you are doing exactly
stealing from your brothers
betraying me or you don't have the right
to decide that future all right we have
the responsibility
you've portrayed everyone you knew
either are worth enemies and for what
somewhat must make amends
Creed Rogue the most Irish Assassin's
Creed video game ever made which isn't
saying much it's not that not that Irish
hey then guys Danny I'm doing pretty
good you guys are sitting real close
together on that couch it's pretty good
there's like all that all this extra
couch over there and it's just like
listen man we got to keep the shot tight
are you saying we take up less couch
than your other guests oh snap
they didn't hear it they didn't hear it
they didn't hear it you're here with a
game we showed uh only two weeks ago but
uh it's actually legitors of the game
yes indeed but we are here alone playing
Borderlands the prosequel
uh yeah Borderlands is out the loading
screens on PC are really short uh uh
it's it's pretty cool oh popping yeah
but still got that that a good
old-fashioned Borderlands pop in you've
been playing this all week long wow I
haven't been playing it too much as you
can tell
Destiny going on oh that's what it was
obviously obviously uh I'm level 14
playing as Athena here riding on my
Stingray they had that stingray in
Unreal Tournament 2004. could it do this
yeah yeah gonna die in some lava nope
Gonna Make It Sweet Bonk how much have
you played so far
it's fine
no it's not fun oh it wasn't fun uh it's
a good thing those loading screens are
fast they are here I go I'm playing got
Aaron Samson in here he's like a level
or two higher than me but Yep this is my
Athena let's take a look at her hello
yep she's all armored and whatnot she
throws a sweet Shield uh don't call it a
Captain America shield and yeah so we're
working for Handsome Jack doing the
doing the
corporate mercenary thing how long are
you into it now oh is that iron there
yes I would say I've played this no more
than five hours
so he's still good
Handsome Jack handsome jackets yeah yeah
technically
well he's not it's not that he's like
good that he's like a Bastion of
morality and like a troubled world it's
just that he's not like
a super maniac
he's a company man you know he's trying
to what am I trying to do this is
handsome or you know like Jack in the
next game or on the earlier game but
after this Pre-Sequel becomes such an
interesting character because he's so
insane that he's really really funny
this one he actually gets shown his very
first entry scene he's getting like the
crap beaten out of him oh he definitely
is kind of feel bad for him
he's not a very intimidating character I
feel bad for him I wouldn't go that far
though the characters talk a lot more in
this version as well like have you how
have you found out in the first couple
of hours like is there more character
development sure there I mean it's much
more in the Borderlands 2 vein right uh
Borderlands was a pretty
vacant uh world if you were kind of
playing by yourself you had to rely on
your friends around to sort of give the
world a lot of Personality Borderlands 2
they like kicked up the personality real
what the hell is this
I thought that was the thing I needed
for requests something totally different
Borderlands 2 kick up the personality a
lot especially with Handsome Jack and
Aaron oh no he's gonna get his second
win he doesn't know me oh but I will
come in for a butt Stomp and ruin his
second win no here aha you can't get a
second win because I killed the guy near
you
look at him and his beanie he's playing
as Wilhelm whose special is to spawn
these two little uh drones
there's a giant squid energized Sugar
Sugar wrath okay yeah that's what they
call it I got a bunch of questions
coming in I'm gonna throw them at you
and number one red hat Drew feelings on
the new vehicles
the stingray is great the moon buggy is
utter garbage really it is dire trash
it's so so bad it's so it handles so
terribly and even anything if you even
hit just a slight piece you'll just go
swerving off track and it's something I
wonder if it has anything to do with the
gravity as well but basically you flip
really easily so you don't just you
don't just tilt it sounds like the
makeup will go completely off course and
you're like yeah you'll just like catch
a little hitch and then all of a sudden
do it do a U-turn and lose all your
momentum and fall into lavender and so
like there's one Quest that like
that I got that was like a race in the
moon buggy cool the moon Buggy's
terrible the race is really unpleasant
oh really oh yeah no it's it's no good
um but this Stingray is pretty neat it
can butt stomp stuff it's like an Unreal
Tournament 2004. oh really sorry I'm
just fun no that's not saying that thing
it's your cultural reference point
that's my yeah right and I climb up here
sure make it uh shishiro asks uh how is
the loot compared to Destiny the loot
compared to Destiny that's a good
question let's take a little oh I can't
look go into your legendaries because
I'm in the oh yeah the vehicle a very
flattering that you think I have
legendary gear at level 14 man no have
they marked your favorite uh or nerfed
your favors had gone like Eric taze and
Destiny look at Tay over there getting
all salty they haven't had time to Nerf
them yet but we got to play with some
legendary weapons and there's some
really cool weapons yeah we got to test
around with some pretty sweet uh freeze
rays and a nice uh automatic laser
shooter that was like really fun to get
our hands on so I do think they're
coming but you gotta earn them have you
got any good drops oh whatever I just
got a drop it's this one it's like a
machine gun that says winter is numbing
uh it
shoots like this and freezes things like
that that rapid I think they're called
the freeze is a new thing right it's
good yeah the freeze is really amusing
because I mean it's like ever since what
Terminator 2 the whole Frieza dude and
then he shatters became like the coolest
thing or Jason X when Jason goes into
space uh he freezes a girl solid and
then smashes her head on the ground and
it shattered in space in space in a
movie in space that marvelous cultural
Touchstone uh digital tastic is there
also a dune buggy that has extendable
scorpion style blade arms I believe this
is a reference to Unreal Tournament
2004.
are there blade arms on that I don't
think there are blade arms on the
stingray feather Dave asks a pretty
great question after both Borderlands
one and two plus all the DLC uh we've
had what might be charged to be called
the suffocating amount of this gameplay
is there anything into so new and fresh
that it could overcome a ton of burnout
like you both of you guys have played a
lot of I know you've played Bunches of
the first two you play quite a lot
Borderlands well right yeah I reviewed
the first two of them for Game Spot oh
sweet and so I played a bunch I didn't
quite get to level 50 on either so I
didn't do the like complete every DLC do
all the like Headhunter like uh raid
boss I didn't kill cromeracks you know
like so I'm not I don't think I'm at the
burnout level that person is describing
so if you're burned out on Borderlands
don't play more Borderlands this is not
gonna unburn you out from Borderlands
but if you're kind of like you know it
was really fun like playing Borderlands
I kind of like that maybe you know if
you're playing Destiny and you're like
God this is just so dry the only amusing
thing in here is weapon descriptions uh
you want something a little more
personality you want something with butt
stomping that's for you and it's really
I mean it's just more of what you love
right sure they added you know less
gravity and and some different guns and
stuff but at the end of the day it's
really more of the same Borderlands game
so if you like that style you're gonna
love this but there's certainly nothing
so completely different I guess it
probably depends a lot on if you like I
like I know you played with Lexi a bunch
for the other two like this is kind of
cool if you have those friends who
you've played a bunch of Orland Square
like is get their band back together
some of the campaigns are really fun
they've done a really good job um they
brought toward back some really great
characters that are so hilarious that
you can't wait to see with their what
Shenanigans they're going to get into
next they're funny they're they're
hilarious writers and it's really it's a
really fun game if you like those kinds
of things when I play these types of
games it's not always like to get the
crazy weapons of the raids it's to go
through the campaign and enjoy the story
and it's awesome to see what they've
done to make a Pre-Sequel they you know
you don't see that a lot in games where
they make where they go early into the
depths of what made Handsome Jack who he
is because I've learned that really
awesome see that's weird because I never
thought of Borderlands is a story driven
game to me it was always like a it was
just a you know Co-op shooter where you
[__] did missions and it's story in
the sense that if you you enjoy silly
characters and silly writing it's really
fun this story is an impactful or like
honest it's more of like a fun
experience and you do talk about some of
the things that you see afterwards like
again like our tour mission is so funny
I reference it all the time because he's
just this guy who hates science so much
somebody sends you out on a mission to
destroy it and that's I think to me like
those are the stories that make the game
worth playing to begin with and it
wasn't until Borderlands 2 that
Borderlands really became more of a
story personality driven game like that
that was a new thing there and then a
lot of like the characters you see here
I mean torg especially wasn't I don't
think he was really introduced until
Borderlands 2 and you know you get you
got Moxie in here but like this early on
I haven't encountered scooter uh there
but there's a new kind of scooter-esque
character whose name is Jenny something
sure she's
sassy and Australia she's so Australian
that's it so like that's another way it
does feel uh a little bit distinct is
like just a ton of Australian accents
which isn't that because this is someone
who doesn't get to hear Australian
accents a lot I'm talking to Randolph
Randy Ramsay
Randolph Randy Ramsay it's fun like it
it adds a little bit well that's what
happens when you make the game in
Australia right
because there are games that are made in
all corners of the world that don't
necessarily don't don't necessarily have
this sort of stamp of that culture on it
LA Noire didn't have lots of Australian
well maybe it did I don't know right but
like there are there are games you know
like The Witcher games like you do feel
you get sort of a connection to polish
that the kind of you sort of feel the
developers culture come through in
saying Borderlands the PC e code is the
best Australian video game ever made who
knew that Australians would inhabit core
knowledge of what games were made I got
some questions
how uh has the oxygen system been
it's really not a detriment at all like
you'll find that even though it'll say
you're running out of air all you do is
kill one bad guy and he drops like heaps
of of oxygen tanks there's I've never
ran out of oxygen once and I didn't
think about it and think oh I need to go
get some oxygen if you play and you're
killing things you're going to come
across it doesn't really change it too
much you mean looking for Sonic air
bubbles yeah you're not drowning yeah no
you and there's plenty of oxygen to grab
for sure and also the butt stomp stuff
and the like being able to run a little
faster and jump a little farther is
definitely a nice change as Sea Christ
does the low gravity Count Anywhere it
doesn't get boring
what low grab stuff what is it what does
it work everywhere and does it get
boring it's not everywhere I mean right
now we're in low anytime you see the
like O2 meter depleting you know anytime
there's no atmosphere you're in Low
Gravity so I can like jump
yep and it's awesome in terms of like
getting those extra jumps um with your
Boost it does help because if you jump
vertically and then you use your Boost
you go up extra high whereas if you jump
forward and then use your Boost you're
gonna get this uh push forward which is
a really nice feel to the game so it
depends on how you use it I enjoyed it
the whole time I never got sick of it I
think it's an awesome change up to the
game that makes it different and again
it's 2014 so everyone's contractually
obliged to have double jumps in the
first person yeah you gotta you gotta
mix up the movement that's how that's
how we figured out you can uh unstale a
game genre apparently my favorite
whether that's true or not remains to be
seen
you can at least attempt to unstale it
uh I'm gonna say something about zero
gravity everyone is oh yeah there's like
more platforming stuff now because
because of that the flow to your jumps
because of the jump pads that they put
in there's more there's like platforms
and they're hiding things
they're hiding guns um really high up on
buildings do they expect you to be
floating around and kind of enjoying it
is that an impact the missions at all
are there like different ways into bases
and stuff or is it still pretty
like Portland's always been about the
shooting variety rather than the actual
like level variety or like this yes no
it's like these things are kind of
serious look at their buddies they oh no
they are my buddies thank you Danny uh
kids green means butter I'm sure there's
just like
there's it's not like you can
yeah I mean it doesn't so like in a lot
of and a lot of uh
encounters happen in areas like this
where I can like jump up to you know up
here to grab ammo and then be blasting
down but then be across the map like
butt stomping all these dudes you're
much more fluid so you are around
you know you are around a lot more you
are sort of encouraged to be jumping
about willy-nilly a little bit more so
like acid comes out of you and you butt
stomp everyone in the chat was freaked
out that you breathe the air of dead
things
well fortunately uh the air that yeah I
guess when you die as in life uh just
neat canisters of everything that's
inside of you spills out onto the ground
and uh that's a circle it's not like
you're inhaling other people's death
Ruffles no no it's like it's sort of
like an instant embalming process where
like the Egyptian doctors like draw your
brain out through your nose and put it
in a jar and then toss that jar on the
ground and depending on how smart you
are it's like a blue a green or like a
legendary brain
if someone never played anything
Borderlands before would like and they
played Borderlands would this game be
the one we're gonna be Borderlands 2.
what do you think oh should they start
with this game you totally could start
with this one there's really nothing
about it that makes you like the story
stuff not understand it I think pretty
good at giving you the background that
you need to understand what the heck is
going on there's a lot of inside jokes
though right so you'll probably miss
those but in terms of at least
understanding the game you'll be fine my
favorite one is still two though I think
two is is better story-wise just because
Handsome Jack is such such a good
character character and he's not that
character in this I mean he's a
character he's got he's got character
but not as much does he have
characteristic characters too not so
much he's funnier and like uh it's hard
to explain like he they give him kind of
like this slap sticky jokey personality
where he's just like I don't know let's
see if it finds out if we get you know
we get burned to death and we'll know
better next time that's funny but I kind
of like the insane murderous Jack that's
just kind of whacked out that's what
makes this game so interesting are those
crazy characters that they employ so the
crazier the better in my opinion can you
do four player claptrap there or
something absolutely
yeah four players uh split screen is
there split screen no games that are
split screen anymore but there's yeah
there's four players there's four new
Vault Hunters Aaron's Wilhelm the dude
who turns into a robot slowly over the
course of the game and uh I am Athena
who has a dope shield and there's also
Niche Nisha who is kind of like a dual
wielding Western Gunslinger and then a
Claptrap and I actually think claptrap
despite some people thinking he's pretty
annoying I would I agree with you he's
pretty annoying he's one of the better
characters because he's he's kind of got
a little bit more depth in terms of what
he can do I actually really like all of
his skills that you can level up like is
that one of those situations where if
you didn't have prior like exposure to
him in the previous games that you
wouldn't find you wouldn't find his
Antics as strong yeah
uh it's entirely possible yeah I mean no
but he's I mean he's he's sort of
written to be that way and I do I think
people like it yeah I think it's I think
it's funny like he entertains me I do
like that he has that like high five
skill that I think we mentioned with
b-boy Maestro says split screen on
Console version
thank you for doing our job for us
Joshua show also or direction also can
confirm I'm gonna level up real quick
that's how I've been playing it before
so I think there's not a lot of split
screen on games anymore
which irks me every single time yeah
did some hot leveling up do that yeah
give us leveling up your Shields ways to
do this stuff with my that name's Athena
uh there's different ways to do all that
stuff won't dive into it now because it
doesn't make for good TV Great Greek
goddess of wisdom War Roman I always
forget which one's which minervous one
Athena's the other can never tell which
one no it's Minerva and Diana 's nope no
no no can we just go back and watch all
of Xena Warrior Princess and we'll
figure it we'll sort it out let's go
back to talking about things
most of this
like
it seems like Borderlands 2 plus um
it's in many ways yeah and I do I think
if you if you can stomach it give
claptrap a shot he is a really fun
character to play
um and it's really cool like all the
different things that can happen when
you play as him he changes
into like six different things they're
all pretty interesting and funny
sometimes not even super helpful but
most the time enjoyable in terms of
entertainment I still feel like I still
feel like I'm killing children when
you're doing that the midgets yeah no
everybody knows that the best killing
children video game is Lord of the Rings
conquests in the final in the final
level you go at you play as Sauron going
to Rampage in the Shire and you're just
like slaughtering Hobbits and it's it's
cruising I'm nothing it's gruesome they
don't like jib or anything but they
really they look like kids they jib no
they don't jib Gib
Borderlands the Pre-Sequel out now on
today and last gen consoles Xbox 360 and
PS3 perfecto
GG for all your old console needs for
all your I still own this console and so
do most of my friends
I really like having it it's good to
dust it off although my 360 red rings
we're gonna be back in a second we've
got the trailer for uh The Evil Within
which uh we're not playing on today's
show but Mary are you doing a live
stream tomorrow yes we should be doing a
live stream of The Evil Within for one
hour I think at 2 p.m tomorrow if
anyone's interested in watching that it
should be pretty scary fun frightening
and I've never seen anything let's see
why it's fun yeah reviews have been like
have there been many reviews posted not
a lot of polygons one IGN's one went up
I think ours didn't because for some
inexplicable reason they didn't send it
to us yeah no it wasn't it wasn't like
widely fine
speculation I don't know but here's a
quick look on giant bump they got one
and we'll have the review up this week
and Mary's going to play tomorrow and do
lots of screaming which is great because
when we're sitting like
20 feet that way we hear her scream and
then we know to look at the video
because in 20 seconds
there's really no enclosure here you can
hear everything yeah between not in the
building shaking it's really a fantastic
place to work thanks moonves we'll be
back in a couple of minutes uh first of
all here's the trailer for The Evil
Within and then uh Jeff Grossman and Don
Michael from giant bomber joining Kevin
Vonore to talk about Bayonetta and 10
out of tens back in a second
foreign
The Evil Within
available now sure why not you guys did
a quick look right we did I haven't
watched it yeah so uh it sounds like uh
the first few hours of it or a real slow
start uh but but Brad has kind of warmed
up to it recently and also the console
versions apparently look kind of crappy
really yeah what did you play on uh they
were playing on PS4 I think but uh yeah
I don't know I haven't touched it I
played it back at E3 in between not
liking survival horror games and right
you know not thinking that that one
looked especially good sure enough all
those things combined to maybe go like I
don't want to play any more of this yeah
you know did Kevin you played it no I
haven't played it actually my uh the
only time I ever moved and saw it was in
a presentation at E3 and I just can't
wait wow that looks really
cheesy but not in that you know wow that
looks fun way but in that I think
they're trying to actually be serious
way so that was that was sort of my
takeaway then I have no idea what the
the actual game has turned out I want to
start with the review at the moment uh
Sean's working on it cool not every not
everybody got Advanced code so we were
one of the ones that had to wait
what are you guys doing you got Advanced
codes so I told them directly uh
directly in person back at E3 that I
didn't think it was a very good game
I don't know yeah it seems like they
would have the opposite reaction it's a
weird world Daniel Dwyer it is a weird
world of 10 out of 10 video games
really [__] Segway uh don Riker if
you're I think the only person in this
building who has played a lot of this
game our review was done by Mark Walton
in the UK okay we couldn't afford to fly
mad for uh 30 minutes
um but uh yeah you've been playing a
bunch of this game yeah I just looked at
my clock and I'm in about 30 hours now
uh beat it on normal I'm kind of working
through on the harder difficulties and
easier ones
stuff now but uh it is a fantastic game
are you reviewing it uh yeah I already
reviewed it give it five stars sweet I
got chainsaws on my feet
yep yep excellent that's the thing
that's going on yeah uh so yeah you'll
see I actually unlocked bayonetta's old
look you get that after you beat the
game but uh I can't say specifics but
there's some other cool unlockables at
the end of the game We're not gonna talk
a lot of that has made its way to the
Internet so it's it's pretty cool
confirmed Yeah so basically just the
moment-to-moment combat this is really
good and I'm probably gonna blow it now
that I'm trying to talk but it's fine
you have to keep talking all right we'll
talk over here instead Bayonetta is a
lady witch and
Umbra because
you cut people
hair Sonic the Hedgehog rings but
they're called Halos now and hair beasts
I can do this did you like the original
Bayonetta yeah it was really cool I
liked the original a lot but uh it
didn't blow me away the way this one
really this one is just fantastic I
think all right why you can switch up on
the Fly here uh you know it's not that
it does anything crazily different than
the first one it's just that I I think
part of it might be timing I think that
like there hasn't been a lot of these
type of character action games coming
out recently
um but also just the level of just the
nuance and the gameplay and the uh you
know encounter to encounter fights are
just incredible let's see if I get into
a big one here is the combat very
similar to the last one it's similar
yeah there's some extra things you can
do this umbrun climax thing now to where
it's kind of like a uh boost to all your
attacks makes them all deadly of course
it's a lot of climax yeah yeah naturally
yeah they had a lot of stuff in the
previous game I think too right
yeah yeah which time yep yeah which time
is a huge thing here that you really
gotta Master uh especially on the harder
difficulties but like check this out so
my flamethrowers my feet here if I twirl
and hit this switches them to ice
flamethrowers okay so that's a fun thing
or ice throwers or something yeah I got
fire here so you can do stuff like if
you hold in the button at the end of any
combo you just do something with that
yep so same thing if you have you know
guns on your feet like in the first one
um but yeah the chainsaws I skate around
on them as much as self-dictated by you
or is it like is there any customization
with that or is it all like there's
customization so like check this out
here if I go in here
actually it's the first one so this is
set a this is set B and I can switch
between them on the Fly by hitting the
uh the right bumper here this looks like
the most confusing thing in the world
it's not at all so this is just what's
on my hands so let's say I want I want
the sword in my hands and on my feet I
probably want chainsaws with my feed
yeah I like James size so
R will switch between the two
and so now yeah chainsaw feed sword arms
and I can switch between that other
layout at any time
um so yeah which time you got to wait
for the tell and then you get out of the
way and then it slows down time you can
do these torture attacks like in the
first one let's kick them into that
that's the thing that happens
sure why not yep
there we go
does it have all the ridiculous uh yeah
okay oh there's it's just constantly
ridiculous yeah so lady crotch how much
lady crotch is in there what matters
that's what I come to Bayonetta for is
late I believe more than maybe any game
I've played there's a whole lot of Lady
crotch going on oh good yep yep
um and it's using cutscenes and stuff
although well we're getting a pretty
good though for a moment why is that
what that I don't
because why wouldn't you I guess she's
you know she's sassy or something I
don't know if you're if you're a
platinum games
she's stylish that intro was pretty
great with all the logos on buses and
nonsense oh at the beginning it was like
all I've seen oh yeah yeah yep there's
much time so like this is not even like
a big boss character like guys like this
will show up fairly frequently wait big
bosses in this uh well yeah that's
that's good okay all right
oh are you are you replaying this
because you want to or you feel obliged
to because of your review oh I mean the
review is done I mean I played a little
bit today just to make sure I was wasn't
Rusty you know going into this but uh
yeah I'm Gonna Keep playing this at home
for sure like I want to beat it on every
difficulty there's like an infinite
climax mode if you beat it on hard to
finish climax mode yep that sounds like
either heaven or hell yeah I'm not sure
I'd say that's like that sketch from Jam
what's Jam
you'd know more about it I was at a UK
thing yeah
I can turn into a bird and shoot little
knives dirt
attorney
so yeah that which time thing is
probably the single mode support
mechanic
um I actually just unlocked this
accessory trip I do this I summon little
demon fellas that will fly around like
little grim reapers that were attacked
for me of course that's fun
is this a game to buy Wii U for
Ah that's just such a hard question as
far as like buying a console for one
year yeah it's kind of a [__] stupid
question is but that's based on like
that and like Mario Kart and like a
couple of other big games Zelda's coming
up at some point obviously uh let me eat
this one no they decided they were done
was all done are they done yeah they're
retired okay it's like a Guitar Hero
situation basically yeah okay we made
too many oh god oh man yep
Zelda Aerosmith was the last straw
the ZZ Top oh yeah
did you get that green day one yeah it's
all the Green Day yeah yeah it's all the
Green Day the intro is amazing so you
can pick up enemies weapons sometimes
like they've got that monsters whatever
you call those
I'm guessing that disappears after a
while
um it's got like its own little health
bar over there so as I use it against
enemies oh it's Mark Echo uh no he is a
young magical boy that turns into a
flying squirrel yeah yeah okay yeah
sorry sick pants uh the story is almost
impossible to follow and again I've
played through this almost three times
now and I just yeah what's going on I've
watched every cutscene it's just
incoherent but yeah he turns into a
squirrel I figured that much out he's
got the fire in those pants I wouldn't
have stepped into the deep water
oh yeah we want to go to a mountain
called thimble Vinter or something along
those lines
it's a great voice acting I'm gonna skip
this so I can get back to fighting
Problem Solver right there yeah I wonder
I don't know what's going on
I think
a lot of the cutscenes in in Bayonetta
one were I mean in some ways some of my
favorite stuff just because it was it
was so crazy yeah and it's all over the
place it was a lot of fun just to see
where they were going to take it next so
hearing that they they do seem to
go there oh yeah in this game also I
think that's cool especially the
beginning the first couple chapters I
mean they just come out swinging
yeah I'm a terrible person because I
never actually finished the first
original bayonet because dark Fighters
came out pretty quickly afterwards right
and then I I had to return to it like
that was definitely like we were we had
two TVs and you know
we were playing both games at the same
time Bayonetta and I was over there
playing Darksiders
uh yeah it's not that this does anything
just crazily different than the first
one doll um it's just that everything is
just so damn good
um this is weird there's a ghost I've
never heard what this is about there's a
ghost couple over there that's in love
yep and you go up and ah get out of here
and they get scared and you break their
bench and they run away you don't have
to break their bench yeah you chose I
mean yeah maybe if you did the different
thing they would stay and help you with
this fight I guess I haven't tried that
I just break the rank every time there's
usually help in there I don't know what
your problem is with love oh you know I
have a pretty good idea what his
problems
I ain't talking about love
oh this is under climax mode so you see
all my attacks are just Bonkers here
yeah it's it's great
oh I feel like we could demo this game
for another four hours and it would just
be this over and over and over and over
again yeah but as you
as just looks like a crazy mishmash of
you know kicks and fire and hair and
everything and kisses yeah and kisses
but as you're playing it it's actually
just super super responsive and you feel
like you totally have a grasp on what
she's doing uh like it's not like you
just hit buttons and crazy [__] happens
well it can if you want to play that way
earlier I was talking to you um at your
desk and you turned and talked to me
like eye contact for like a good eight
seconds while playing this game because
you challenged me
I think I got hit a lot all right that's
a Bayonetta two out on the Nintendo Wii
U h
post haste currently no it's in two
weeks or so two weeks to late October
they were confident with this bad boy
and it comes with the first one too oh
yeah of course yeah and that plays well
on here too excellent cool thanks very
much appreciate it thank you you can put
that pad in there or if you want you can
just keep talking to us while doing that
oh yeah yeah oh uh bayonet two one of uh
eight games to only uh have achieved the
10 of 10 on gamespot.com oh yeah uh you
and you uh wrote some reviews for those
games in fact dude the only two people
left in the building who have written
any tens of those eight yeah yeah I mean
you were number one with Ocarina right I
was yeah yeah Ocarina of Time ended up
being the first 10. at that time we were
a video game spot so we were we were the
separate crew that hid in the back and
used the word hella a lot and then
Gamespot was PC focused and and very
much like one of these animals doing
here
um so when I came back after a so they
they sent Ocarina on a Friday and the
review could run Monday so I got the
cartridge went home did you sleep no a
little bit
uh that there's actually I think the
that experience was documented on the
site in text form somewhere weirdly
enough
um
and wanted to give it a 10. and
basically uh that led to a conversation
that was probably about an hour long
with Vince Brody who was one of the
founders of Gamespot and he was the one
who was in charge of all editorial the
three founders of Gamespot were kind of
like they were they were focused like
fence was editorial yeah uh Pete was
kind of the tech and then John Epstein
was business so was it just you and him
having a job yeah he called me into his
office and basically just tried to poke
holes in it over and over again in a way
that at the time I thought was actually
really frustrating because it was you
know he was saying like this game is not
voice acting how can you say the sound's
a 10 this is when we were scoring on
component scores so it was what was this
this one's Graphics gameplay sound uh
value and reviewers tilt
uh which makes reviewers tilt actually
made perfect sense
it's not worth it it's not gonna end it
up I'm worth getting into
um and so he just sat there and kind of
poked holes like wouldn't it be better
for that voice acting wouldn't it be
better if I had this I was like well you
know the standards of the console all
those other stuff like if these are the
policies that we review by absolutely
not this is a sound 10 all the way uh
and he kind of grilled me on it for a
while and then at the end of it went
all right if that's what you want to do
which was actually the worst thing he
could have said
um but yeah we ended up going through
and giving it a 10. um the thing that
always happens I I was really excited
when I saw the 10 it was the first 10
since I've been working at Gamespot and
I always remember like there was just
always backlash there's always a part of
the community who just fundamentally
thinks this one was better in the series
or yeah yeah you run into stuff like
that but I think you know the thing we
ran into in the early days was that the
word under 10 said perfect right and so
it was it was it wasn't necessarily
about other games it was just about no
games perfect any game could be better
like even today people refer to it as
the Perfect Score which is kind of yeah
and I think since then like we you know
like when we redesigned the scoring
system on Gamespot to remove the
component scores and all the other stuff
at that time we took perfect off of it
and made it say Prime instead which you
know it was was the best word we could
come up with at the time I guess but uh
uh you know the the idea you know and we
had to justify it in a way and saying
like you know it ended up saying like
it's as perfect as a game game can be by
today's standards and you know it's like
it was like a back explanation for it
that worked well at the time but uh
eventually yeah like moving it to Prime
and saying like you know yeah you're
right no game can be perfect but like
who stopped this yeah this is a dumb
argument uh was the right move I think
uh next game up with solo caliber yeah
who did that one I want to say that was
a James milky review okay was that
in-house or freelance was it house yeah
he was in House at that point he he came
out I think he was doing user reviews
for us we brought him in
um and and so he was with the site for a
while and I want to say he reviewed that
and gave that a 10. you agree with that
then oh 100 it's like top five games of
all time for me did you start doing user
reviews as well Kevin yeah that's
actually uh kind of how I got into
Gamespot was I did use reviews and I was
a moderator on the site for years we had
a pretty hot pipeline for a while of
hiring people out of the community
Carolyn as well Community I kind of was
involved in the community but yeah yeah
came in at a different angle uh Chrono
cross
yeah Chrono cross this is probably the
one that comes up a lot uh I mean no
because who talked about Chrono cross in
this day and age that one was uh that
one was interesting uh because it was
freelanced out uh so it was someone who
was not on staff uh you know we were
paying someone paying some mercenary out
there to to review the game for us and
uh it came back at 10 and it was the
sort of thing where it's like okay now
we're kind of in a bind because no one
on staff has played this game no one can
vouch for it one way or the other which
is kind of what I'm a bayonet actually
but we'll get into that yeah so you end
up in this situation where you're like
you know I'm I'm gonna you know I tried
to kind of I remember trying to poke
kind of holes in it the defense brought
away to some extent
um but it got to a point where it's like
okay we kind of need someone else to to
vouch for it so we went to another
freelancer that was on our staff that
had also played it and said like
what you think you think this game's a
10 and the response was oh yes
absolutely so like okay well
we're gonna go through and give it a 10.
so how I remember it going down is the
review got published it was live and
then I responded and said all right it's
up now and you know that's the that's a
perfect game and then the response from
the guy that uh we had to check and said
oh I never said it was perfect
on that one
how did you feel then going up with Tony
Hawk Pro Skater 3 that was number four
that game's incredible yeah the game is
still amazing yeah uh Tony Hawk 2 got a
9.9 where are you gonna go from there
not that it was about yeah that but you
know uh if you look at Tony Hawk three
on the PlayStation 2 they pet that game
hat online in it before they had issued
the official network adapter so you know
you could plug in like a weird USB
ethernet adapter and play online like
you know like the the length they went
to in that game
um and they completed the scoring system
by adding revert and all that other
stuff like like Tony Hawk three was
where they finally linked it all
together and it looked amazing at the
time that Tokyo level had the round
bowls and the cool sound effects and
stuff Great Sand track again yeah yeah
terrific soundtrack like I know a lot of
people go like oh two's better they're
wrong I thought I would I thought the
consensus was that three was Tony Hawk
two was great yeah like like four gets
into an area where it's like now it's
kind of like larger areas and stuff like
they started getting away from and they
have to like obviously they can't just
put out the same game again that's
Activision of today not the activism
um and so this is just Bam Margera in
Call of Duty and yeah Bam Margera is
playing a concert in my hometown at the
end of this month okay I don't know I
don't know I don't know what that means
his name is just on the Marquis band oh
yeah oh yeah
shows up with an accordion and starts
you know hey what's up guys oh right and
then I think it's like electronic music
and he sings oh that makes sense
is he in a him cover band that would
make too much sense uh his girlfriend as
I understand it is from my hometown so
he is he is there a fair amount
um anyway yeah Tony Hawk three uh is
incredible and anyone that disagrees is
actually completely wrong well if you
think Tony Hawk 2 was a better game
you're [__] wrong that was 2001 that
it was seven years until the next one
wow which and this one is quite
contentious as well it was Grand Theft
Auto Four Grand Theft Auto Four yeah
with Justin Calvert
um uh we gave a review of that I
completely agree I absolutely adore GTA
4 but I know that I'm probably in the
minority no GTA 4 is an amazing game
yeah I think I agree with every one of
these except for chronographs so far oh
really those are some of the best games
of all time or anything that when Ford
came out it was like legitimately
incredible like I remember before yeah
yeah of course that was interesting I
mean because I because then I Was Here
by this point it's actually interesting
because we'd had we'd had 10 submitted
before but then they never Jason Ocampo
wanted to give Half-Life 2 a 10. oh yeah
we said no and he wanted a crisis attend
the first crisis correctly the first
crisis I think he wanted to give a 10. I
liked crisis um but Half-Life 2 is a
good Shout
but uh oh God damn it but GTA 4 I think
we were we were actually uh going back
and forth because at that point we had
the 0.5 increments and everything yes
and then so it was like okay so is it a
nine five or is it a ten nine five ten
nine five ten we ended up landing on the
ten actually it was 9-5 on PS3 and it
was 10 on 360 I think was it yeah one of
them wasn't 10. well I know that we gave
the PC version a nine okay um when that
came out but we did give GTA it was the
first ten it was in years and years and
then the same year we gave yes another
four maybe the most content it might be
actually the most contentious 10. I'd
love to hear what Riker that has to
think about this one oh oh really oh I
don't know metal gear solid four oh okay
yeah
um so a game that I stand for three
right
I I think there's an argument for any
one of the four the official familiar
solids you can argue for any one of
those four being the best yeah I [__]
love Metal Gear Solid 4. yeah when we
did our uh retrospective a couple years
ago and I got the chance to I you know I
just pulled that out and started playing
I was like oh God this is so right on
the money for that time I was so it's
still I really stand by that I mean
there are a few reviews we always have
those couple reviews it was like yeah
maybe in retrospect I was a little a
little excitable over that one but man I
will stand by that 10 just as much as I
stand by that nine for the original
assassins were you like nervous at all
being like from the community and
knowing the importance and like you know
were you nervous at all that like you
weren't sure if this was that type of
game like what's the what's the mindset
there I mean honestly the when so one of
the the kind of the last big things I
did at Gamespot was kind of write that
review system to be right to go from the
component score system down to the half
points and stuff
and the I originally actually wanted to
go five stars with that stuff and you
know we've kind of decided on a middle
ground with that stuff and
by design
that should make tens easier to give
yeah we took perfect off of it like it
wasn't designed to make scores higher it
was designed to be like you know let's
just put the power back in the editor's
hands get away from this mathematical
formula that makes less and less sense
as we add more reviews to the site so
that was when all the Revere still it's
in gameplay yeah like that stuff kind of
went away it was replaced by that emblem
system that I thought was cool
um I missed emblems a lot yeah yeah me
too uh it was it was the the case where
the the original idea behind emblems was
We were supposed to be able to add them
on a really regular basis as games
changed and then getting the design
resources to do that proved to actually
be a completely different story so I
remember hearing from Ryan Mack that
sometimes when you submitted that the
algorithm wasn't known so when you hit
like publish with all those that you
didn't actually know what the final
score was going to be down to the
decimal we had uh there was a an
engineer named Clovis Addison who was
right there yeah and he was uh he made a
spreadsheet for me that had the math in
it okay so it was like gameplay times
point three and you know it was just
like whatever it was a weighted formula
yeah so gameplay mattered the most
gameplay and reviewers tilt were equal
uh value and Graphics I want to say were
equal and then sound was the lowest
that's great yearly made the yeah so it
ended up being that every every time you
moved reviewers tilt up a point it added
0.3 to the overall score
um and so
the one thing that did happen is that
the rounding that the site used was
different than the rounding the
spreadsheet used right so you would
enter something that would come up eight
seven and put it up and it'd be an eight
six and you'd be like no whatever and
then the video reviews had to be like
redone I heard because okay by that by
the time we were doing video reviews
like the the ability to preview stuff on
the site was a little bit a little bit
better but uh the thing that would
happen is like oftentimes as part of the
peer review process of everyone reading
the review and commenting on it you
would see a score change a little bit
here and there uh based on those
conversations people be like you say the
value is an eight but when I read this
it sounds like a four or a seven or
something you know so like all those
tweaks would happen and those
conversations did happen like one of the
things that people don't aren't aware of
and I didn't I kind of didn't appreciate
until I joined three years ago was the
amount of peer reviewed it happened so
every review like basically gets sent
around every single editor on staff and
is scrutineered almost yeah I mean
traditionally I mean when I started it
goes copy edit first is how it was done
before we don't have a copy editor right
now but we go to copy edit first and
then it was it goes back you know to the
editor puts in all the changes it puts
into the system when we used to have a
department that actually then entered
those into the CMS that was a really
that was great laborious way of doing it
yeah but uh now I mean we just you know
but but then it goes around the entire
editorial team and everybody gets to
chime in and let me tell you there if
people think that we just lazily throw
stuff up onto the site I think Bayonetta
went through three rounds of QA oh yeah
I mean there are reviews that we've
delayed for almost a week yeah um and
there have been times I've a couple
reviews I've killed
um in the past just because it did it
just didn't get to where it needed to be
too divisive or just no just that it
wasn't written well or didn't argue the
score or in the multiple rewrites didn't
really get there and uh you know there
have been a few times where we've
reassigned based on stuff like that but
crazy at number seven was a Super Mario
Galaxy 2. oh yeah which was tamekshay
right yes yeah and that was that was a
fun conversation I mean typically what
these meant when you know when when I
was you know after you know when when uh
Justin was was kind of in charge of this
stuff it was all of us Gathering into
Justin's office and like for an hour two
hours whatever and throwing around every
single pro and con made letting making
the reviewer really argue the point you
know being Devil's Advocate whenever it
made sense
um and I'm very good at being a devil's
advocate
um so but yeah smg2 dog stoop it's a
pretty great video game
what'd you say
oh really Tom originally submitted that
yeah I probably was a 10. yeah he
that's what I think this is a 10. yeah
this game's
I mean actually I would say it's pretty
close to if something could be called
perfect yeah like I'd say that's that's
a game that really kind of deserves to
be thrown into that category zero
complaints about this game at all yeah
yeah and that was number seven the
number eight uh we had to wait a couple
of years but uh bayonet too
um so yeah we're kind of in a situation
there where we have a it went from you
know I remember going off reading like
uh old Amiga magazines and actually PC
Gamer had until until a couple years ago
had the 100 like scale where it was
everything from zero to a hundred
um Gamespot was on the sort of 20 points
for uh no it was like individual
increments it was 100 points and then
when we changed it it was technically 19
points because the lowest score was 1.0
oh you couldn't get it uh you couldn't
get a zero or a 0.5 or whatever that's
why uh big rigs over there is a 1.0 they
managed to get it in a box and put it
out that's close enough
um yeah so so we changed it to that that
scale and then now what I don't I don't
actually know what you guys do yeah so
it's ten point now this is essential now
yeah yeah essential is the the term and
obviously you kind of that's pretty prom
when you form Giant Bomb you kind of got
your own way to the Five Star Wars I did
the thing I wanted to do and just made a
five star scale at that point that like
I actually uh made the argument that
Gamespot should have moved to that when
it redesigned but it didn't happen we
wouldn't have the problems with
Metacritic you guys have though isn't
that like a we don't know we're actually
we translate to Metacritic better than
any other Outlet out there enter you
think so with the five point our four
and our five stars get colored green our
three star gets colored yellow are one
and R2 get colored red and do they I
don't care what other outlets give games
and how we match up with on that scale
but our four and our five star reviews
are favorable our three stars are like
the and then our one or two are like
yeah what would you think if say like
some of the bigger sites did convert to
fives are like with all of the weird
like messed up
responsibility stuff that's happening
with like Publishers paying developers
based on their Metacritic scores and
stuff like that like as reviewers our
duty is to the people that are
interested in information about which
games they want to buy the whatever the
industry does behind that is something
that a reviewer especially cannot
concern themselves with uh so you know
like I think those deals are not
necessarily great for developers and
they should think twice about signing
them yeah but you know that's that's
obviously you know they at some point
want to do the deal and if that's that's
what they have to do that's what they
have to do
um but yeah I mean ultimately you know
we we have to serve the audience of
people that trust us to be open and
honest about uh the quality of these
games uh so like you know Metacritic is
the last thing I think about when when
doing this stuff after the fact I'll go
look and go oh we're the lowest in
metacritically why does everyone like
this game so much what the hell is wrong
I just look at it and go like these
people are idiots and then move on
so drive clubs didn't get a five out of
five no it's not all right no it did not
there was a very old school uh it was
very like classic in a weird way of like
having people uh come at me over Drive
Club it's been a long time since anyone
has and um it was kind of fun in a weird
way it was like oh how quaint you people
still do this weird eight days way back
then yeah well that stuff was whatever
that was I mean that was like the stuff
of like giving Zelda an 8.8 and then
Mario Sunshine I gave an eight yeah
which stirred up a similar thing was
just like it was like me and Alex just
re like getting emails and just laughing
and just going like what are these
people yeah okay man sure whatever okay
one of my favorite phenomenon that used
to happen after after Giant Bomb was
created is I'd get a lot of messages
saying well if the old Game Spot guys
were still here they'd never give Crisis
crisis two is is a 10 it's five stars
it's like if the old and it's like have
you seen the giant palm reading let me
throw you over there turn that one your
way and that's always the the strangest
one where it's just like somehow of a I
mean it's good you kind of uh go along
and people kind of put you up on a
little little pedestal after a while
it's like oh the good old days well that
happened with Destiny as well I guess a
couple of weeks ago
similar kind of yeah I mean we ended up
actually like having the the exact same
score I I actually heard yeah I I mean
we gave it a three out of five right so
you guys gave it like a 6-0 right yep so
mathematically it's the same
automatically it's exactly the same
thing the math works out
um yeah but yeah I actually didn't hear
from anyone about Destiny yeah when that
review went up it was very much like a
yeah I guess I can't really argue with
that I'm playing it and really like it
but yeah those are all valid I mean the
a lot of the drive Club reaction was
that way too it was just Eric Tay who
was complaining about Destiny well
whatever they ruined assault rifles for
him so I I've actually been telling him
today he just needs to never play that
game ever again okay just like Brad and
DotA great review for that coming up
soon as well yeah yeah free video games
thanks very much for coming on that's uh
I wonder when the next one will be
number nine
any any takers who knows
what Tony Hawk reboots okay
Sony Hawk ride two yeah yeah
um
Advanced Warfare
uh maybe I mean anything anything is
possible any game can be awesome any
game could be [__] let's have the one
conversation we don't have just one one
anymore we have three ones
are more interesting yeah you're not
you're not digging out uh games from
Walmart store shelves and stuff anymore
either yeah they just show up on Steam
now all sorts of [__] just shows the
flood of stuff on Steam is insane yeah
craziness all right gentlemen thanks
very much going on appreciate it that's
a show for this week we done uh Mary do
you have any idea what's on next week's
show
nope all right tune into the lobby games
five 2PM Pacific uh thanks so much
hanging out and uh we'll see you guys
next week adios